تعد فاطمه الميلاد اصغر نحاله في محافظه
القطيف شرقي السعوديه ورثت شغفها في تربيه
النحل من والدها الذي عمل مربيا للنحل
فاطمه نجحت في تحويل هوايتها الى مشروع
ناجح ينتج نحو 800 كيلو جرام سنويا من
العسل والذي يستهدف الاسواق المحليه
والخليجيه المزيد مع مراسلنا على اللعبه
منذ صغرها ارتبطت بالنحل بدافع الترفيه
والاستكشاف امتلكت اول خليه في منحل
والدها وهي في عمر الخامسه عشر فاطمه
الميلاد اصغرون حاله في محافظه القطيف شرق
السعوديه والتي تمتلك اليوم ما يصل الى
200 خليه من النحل
بدايه في تربيه النحل كانت مرحله استكشاف
مع الوالد وحب الاطلاع على عالم النحل
بعدها حاول تنفرد بخليه واحده الخليه
الواحده هذه تمكنت من ادارتها بشكل كامل
بعد ما تمكنت من ادارتها بشكل كامل
لاستشرت الوالد في امتلاك من حل صغير
متنقل وانفردت ب 50 خليه وخمسين خليه هذي
ما شاء الله خلال خمس سنوات من عمري 15
سنه لحد العشرين سنه انفرت بمئتين خليه
[موسيقى]
منذ الثامنه صباحا تبدا النحاله فاطمه
يومها في متابعه خلايا النحل والتاكد من
سلامتها ونظافه المياه علاقتها مع النحل
اكسبتها مزيدا من الصبر والدقه بشكل يومي
لازم اتاكد ان الخلايا تكون سليمه
الاطارات موضوعه بشكل سليم اتاكد من نظافه
الماي اتاكد من كل شيء كل شيء سليم تقريبا
اتواجد في المنحه من ثمان الصباح لحد 4:00
العصر طوال انا فتره موجوده في القطيف لما
اكون برا القطيفه اتواصل مع الوالد بشكل
يوم انه يحضر ويتاكد لي من سلامه الخلايا
[موسيقى]
نجحت فاطمه في تحويل شغفها في تربيه النحل
الى مشروع تجاري ينتج ما بين 600 الى 800
كيلو سنويا من عسل السدر وزهور الربيعي
والمانجروف
وتستهدف منتجاتها السوق المحلي والخليجي
بالنسبه للانتاج السنوي ينتج سنويا حوالي
من 600 الى 800 كيلو من ثلاثه انواع من
الاعسار عسل السدر وعسل زهور الربيع وعسل
المانجروف والحمد لله الانتاج ما يقتصر
على السوق المحلي فقط بل حتى دول الخليج
يصدر لهم وايضا تركيا وان شاء الله باقي
الدول نتوسع في هذا المجال من القطيف علي
اللقبي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات